[MUSIC PLAYING]
It just made
sense to us that
the grandest cinematic
events in Marvel history
should be executed in full IMAX.
The level of ambition in
these films is pretty high.
We needed equipment that could
help us fulfill that ambition.
As filmmakers, it's an
amazing tool for us-- the way
that it captures light, the
way that it captures color.
They're fantastic cameras.
The chip is incredible.
It's at a resolution
that is unprecedented.
The IMAX screen has a different
height than a traditional movie
screen.
Having that extra
verticality gives us
a wider range of
how we frame and how
we shoot these characters.
It's just presented on
a much grander scale
than the traditional
movie theater.
[MUSIC PLAYING]